so we start immediately with the science
so just just one slide about why we want
to do singer scientific and the
motivation for for us to do this thing
is because we want to understand the
progeny of complex tissues like the
brain and the problem is that of course
this is very complicated
this tissue is very - genius and it's a
- teen years in many terms it's 13 years
for example in the morphology in the
size of the cells in activity in the
connectivity in many aspects and this is
just one example of a tissue a very
complicated tissue that we want to study
now before we start to discuss the
technical details just two basic
questions and the first one is why do we
want to do an ASIC and the short answer
is that basically I'm a Sikh is a
systematic readout and today with the
technology we have we can measure it in
a very high quality we can measure it hi
a genome-wide we can measure it with
high specificity and I just divot II and
this is all due to the specificity of
DNA binding and the hypothesis test
canary behind this kind of measurement
is that the transcriptome with the whole
contain enough information about all
these several properties that I just
discussed that the tissue is endogenous
like morphology electrical activity in
mathematics in other properties now the
second question is energy want me to ask
himself before diving into this
challenge is a why doing single cell and
just an analogy I put this food basket
and to study this this mix of foods what
we used to do is in the tissue level it
basically take all these mix of foods
and in order to study the component and
all the properties of this put
everything into one blender mix
everything and then try to answer
questions about the property of this of
these foods but I think quite long time
ago people figured out that it's
actually very difficult to answer
questions about particular elements of
this of this mix and and because we
basically average out everything and if
the mix is autogenous we we basically
lose all the signal instead and another
idea is to take each each one of these
foods and put it in individual blender
and then analyze the composition of this
food and then we can basically answer
particular questions about each one of
this element of the of the foods and
what we want to do is basically the same
with since we want to take a very
complicated tissue like the brain
dissociated into single cell suspension
and then put each cell in a in a
different compartment and analyze its
composition so this is basically the
motivation and a little bit of
background now I will move directly and
briefly explain a little bit of the
molecular biology behind these single
cell protocols
so basically when we say anything
we always actually do Syrian Isaac and
when we talk about that the normal
protocol we start with with with
basically sense we break them we get an
A this called IC step then we use a web
subscription that basically
copy they are they into DNA then this is
called the transplant synthesis now in
bulk experiments basically we have many
many cells sometimes people start with
millions of cells we like them we get
tons of RNA we can reverse transcribe it
and get a lot of cDNA then it's easy we
can immediately continue into standard
library path into sequencing but in the
case of single cell of course what we
have is the single cell and that's the
whole idea
and what's happening that we end up
after the completion step with very
little material so what we need to do
from practical reasons in order to still
handle these samples and measurement we
need to amplify this material basically
people use there's two ways two main way
to do it one is within the total kitchen
and one is with PDL and the potiphar I
will discuss today use PCR to do this
amplification now one of the main key
features of this protocol that I'm
describing forcing yourself in a
sequencing is the idea of tagging the
molecules before we amplify them so
remember again the first step is
basically similar we'd like to sense we
get there and any then we develop IV but
now we will zoom in into one particular
RNA molecule and we mostly work with
polyadenylated the name and will explain
the process so in the in the mix we have
about subscription planet which is poly
poly key final with a known tail on the
pipeline then what happen is that the
rocket a started to copy the name and
when it gets to the end this family of
the transcriptase enzymes
mm anything usually add when he gets to
the end of the molecule we add 10 to end
three nucleotides and they are with with
high ten cccc in the same mix what we
usually have is a glittery Oregon that
we call templates which Oregon that just
we add to the reaction in high
concentration and since its high
concentration and since we have on the
on the clip outside of this oligo GGG
this oligo will tend to hybridize to the
CCC and then the reverse transcriptase
enzyme will continue copy into the same
first read just than the cDNA this same
Oregon that we call template to illegal
and this whole process called the
template switch and what we get at the
end is if we forget now about the anime
stand and we just look at the cDNA what
we get is there basically we have the
cDNA which is the copy of the cocktail
and in Monaco we have the UM line which
is something we add using these
templates which are eco which is a set
of six random and nucleotides that will
be the tag the unique tag to these
specific molecules of a molecule after
the west encryption and most important
we have a handle how to amplify this
molecule now because we have on on this
side and on this side both on the 5055
side of this molecule we have known
sequence so now we can come with finals
and amplify this is the next step
basically we can use the single final
PCR
because because this final and is
primary have the same sequence and
amplify this material which again
remember it's a single stem six fingers
in a pool of RNA molecule or copy of
that anymore
into amount a large amount of material
that we call the fingers and cDNA
library and this is the amplified
material now why why do we need this to
add this tag that we call unique
molecular data file or you and mine so
after the Vance transcription again the
molecule looks like this we have the
mRNA we have the handles deployments and
we have this your mind but now since we
use PCM you can imagine that if we have
a large set of molecules that are
illustrated by this small number of
molecule after PCR what happened is that
the PCR amplification is not perfectly
uniform and thus each molecule may be
amplified with different efficiency so
what we get is that different molecules
will be represented differently in the
amplified material and this is not so
great because what we are interested is
is to quantify what was the pool of
molecules before the PCR but this is
actually why we have the mind so one now
when we take this full of silly
amplified DNA molecule and we sequence
them what we get is we get leads and
then we analyze those leads and what we
can see that a prince for example came
from this molecule three Reed's came
from this molecule at cetera but
actually now we can we are able to go
back from the pool of the amplified
material to the pool that was before the
amplified amplification and basically
say no it doesn't matter how many rings
it matters how many molecules and each
one of these is actually one molecule
yeah and now I'm talking about molecules
are not talking about genes it can be
that this molecule in this molecule
other than the same gene
again to illustrate this we can think
about this example again it's two cells
they have they expressed a similar genes
but with different abundant so if we
focus on number of the blue molecules in
cell 1 we have four molecules while
insert two we have only two blue
molecules so we make a left at lysis of
a prescription and till amplification
again the education is not perfect so we
amplified we get the PCL and then
remember that the blue molecule
represents a single gene but if you look
at the labeling this blue molecule got
the green tag while this blue molecule
goes a gray tag and here again each blue
molecule got the different tags so then
we amplified and then we put together
all the blue molecules so again if I
look at cell one what I see
again I don't look at how many pins I
look at how many different molecules and
inside inside to so the final
quantification that I want to make is
that instead one we had four molecules
while in cell two we have to behave two
molecules and this again represent the
and what we are interested in is the
quantification of the initial state the
amount of molecules we had in the
original set and again this is something
that we can do only due to the
introduction of the introducing the um I
before them replications now the last
type of the protocol is to take this
amplified material the cDNA from a
single cell and to prepare it to human
sequencing and also of course we want we
don't want to run a single cell on the
whole
we want to one a hundreds of sales on on
single lane and for this we need to move
another barcode which will enable us to
multiplex the nm sense so we do this
library preparation of this protocol if
we're using TN fine and this is
basically similar to the next element
and Excel protocol and so we start with
again large relatively large demand and
nanograms of single cell cDNA and this
is how it looks after the amplification
again I think I'm looking now in a
single molecule so it's a double strand
now again we have one side with the
quality and one side with the umi we are
interested to sequence only the 5 Prime
in this protocol because the 5 prime
contained information about the you
might end it contain enough information
about the gene because we can lead the
beginning of the molecule and then it's
enough in order to align it to the
transcriptome and say which gene is so
now we basically load the 10 5 and with
Holy Ghost that contains the in when a
doctor so we have one in an adapter on
this line on the first hand side and we
need to add the second illuminate doctor
so this is basically inside these
articles that the teen 5 is loaded with
the pn5 is is the transpose own it will
basically cut the DNA and into those
those Oracle's then we have a step of
isolating the 5 5 of these molecules and
this is how the final time varies so
final molecules in the library for
sequencing we look like on the
five-pound side is again it's the same
thing we have the finer which is the
Illumina adapter we have the you mind
the five-point size of the gene of the
cDNA and on the other side we have
basically and the second big when I
adapt oh and what we call a cell barcode
which just is that is just there in
order to allow us to multiplex many
cents on the same Illumina and a name so
this is basically the last step of the
test of the molecular biology and now
this material is ready for signal now to
perform this protocol we started to use
about three years ago and we don't
system very briefly the freelance system
is a commercial micro fluidics platform
that allows you to perform basically
cell capture and all the deities the
birth of kitchen and VCR on chip in a
very tiny chambers that are all
controlled with the pulse system and
this is a very beautiful engineering and
the volumes of the reaction makes
everything they efficient reactions so
this is a advantage of of this platform
the second and nice advantage of this
platform is that you can image a preset
so we can take basically after we
capture their cells on the D smoke
frigate chip we can image each
individual cell and what you see here is
only the zooming into the exact capture
site and we can produce this report you
can see the cells on this capture site
and you can i if you look at the cells
that i particularly highlight you can
see that different sizes different
morphologies and different size and we
can quantify those cells and we can also
know where the case is that it's not a
single cell oh it's
and not sale at all oh it's a dead set
and then we can basically eliminate
those cells and avoid to analyze them
and this is very important in
single-cell analysis to avoid all cases
of tablets so this is basically the
second nice advantage of this platform
and today of course it little bit
important to say that maybe the main
disadvantage of this platform is that it
still it it's a low foot put so you can
capture only 96 cells on a single run in
these kind of chips now I'm going to
briefly go into the last step after you
acquire this kind of data from enough
large enough number of cells and you
have a nice data set so the next step
you want to do is to analyze this data
and I'm going to describe briefly the
approach we took and again I will say
that pointer there is a explosion of
methods and I will just describe one
method that we use in order in the in
the papers that we publish in the last
two years so the general theme in this
analysis of basically thing as an
experiment is that we want to look at
the totality and basically the teaming
that we want to take this full data set
which is genome-wide so what you get is
a big matrix you have jeans on the walls
and samples and cells on the columns and
now what you want to do basically you
want to get clusters or goods of
coagulated or core groups of similar
cells and we call them classes in these
analyses and basically they are
potentially de novo cell types or cell
States under standard
this is not related to the to the
vaccine protocol that I am going to
describe quite general the first step
you want to do in such analysis is to do
a feature selection feature selection
means to use the data set from the food
from all the all the genes that describe
each cell into a small set of genes that
are the most relevant that contain
enough information but do not contain
and loans and this is standardly in
single cell a I think today many people
use this kind of approach basically
talking the log of the CV versus the log
of the main meal fit a line and then
select for the top genes that are
involved this line is fitted line as the
most highly informative energy and again
this is not based on standard just by an
filter but on this feat of the CV versus
lean approach after indeed the feature
selection you get used a to fit so means
that you go from 20,000 genes into
whatever the top 1000 genes or three
thousand genes and then you can start
basically doing your analysis and the
goal is to take this reduced data set
and create something that is flatter so
something that you can look at basically
grouping the similar cells together and
the similar genes together then you can
start to look at the data so that then
procedure we we took is called we call
it a texting mainly because it's based
on the spin algorithms spin algorithm
briefly is an algorithm to solve
distance matrix s or correlation matrix
s
into one dimensional order so it's not a
clustering algorithm but it's a sorting
equipment developed by agent managed lab
about more than ten years ago basically
the steps that this backspin tank is
basically they deal to do binary split
to take this data divide it into 2
groups that are really separable and
then repeat the same the same process on
the subgroups and then continue doing
this splits until we don't have enough
information to split the sets perfectly
if we look at the first split we take
the data without it when they mentioned
into a one dimensional order of the
genes and the samples and again this
means that we use the spin and whatin
and the spin algorithm will sort the
cell for example and you will put cells
that are close to each other close to
each other in this one dimensional order
and this is very important because it
reduced the problem of how to split the
data into two chunks into a much more
simple problem because now we have only
the number of possibilities is reduced
to the number of of cells and this is
everything is here is done on the
correlation matrix in a vacant so after
we solve the matrix the correlation
matrix it has usually some structure
like it went in here and this is
illustrated I'm just illustrating the
correlation matrix of example cells by
sense and usually if you look at those
then blue squares represent clusters of
and now the past that is not part of the
spinner going them is to find the
optimal platform into these correlation
mappings and for this I developed some
heuristics on to do this and basically
you can appreciate that those kind of
points that are between the squares they
are potentially good points to split the
data into two chunks and this is
basically what I'm doing then after you
split this set of sales this data into
two chunks you can also divide the genes
into the genes that are more specific or
most relevant to the first chunk or in
the left or the second chunks on on the
right and what you get is basically a
group of cents again on the column and a
group of relevant genes and a second
group of cells with the second group of
relevant genes and this is the basic
step of this big spin algorithm and now
what we are going to do is just to
repeat this so after the first page we
get two chunks we can take each one of
them and repeat that the same procedure
again
so sort find by point ends P okay and
this is how it will look after the first
feed and this is how it will look after
the second and basically we will repeat
this until we get to the number of
splits requested by the user so this is
a parameter so the maximum number of
clusters possible is to ^ number of
splits but usually it will be less than
this because if then we can cannot find
more variability it will just not split
the the cluster so after the first page
after the second place after the first
bit it
and now I show one small example on a
toy data so this is a toy data that we
generated generated by joylynn among in
the lab and it illustrates what happen
if you just apply the spin algorithm so
if you just decide this spinner boy can
spin nose very nicely to sort the cells
and the genes into a great one
dimensional order but you cannot find
those borders between the groups between
this cluster so it's not another organ
that can identify these kind of blocks
so this is where best thing can come
into action and this is how it looks for
example after two speeds and you can see
that for example in two splits we were
supposed to get up to four clusters but
actually we see here three clusters
because this cluster for example cannot
be splitted anymore
so the algorithm just stop splitting
while if we were now going to continue
and do more splits in the backspin for
example after six split this is the
picture that we are going to see and as
you can appreciate this is a quite good
assembling the groups of cells and group
of key relevant genes that are basically
relevant even that this matrix contains
basically a lot of noise as you can
appreciate from the background
yes so that's all about the data
analysis and there and the technical
protocol and now I will hand there to
bundle okay so now we'll continue from
an it's presentation and give an example
of how we have applied
the techniques of the myth has talked
about single cell RNA sequencing to the
identification of cell types within the
ellipsoid lineage which is the major
cell type that we are interested in my
lab so article inter sites that are a
glial cell types in the central nervous
system that produces smiling which is
this insulating membrane that insulates
the axons of neurons and then allows the
fast transmission of electrical impulses
within the central nervous system and
this also all inventor sites also have
function providing metabolic support to
the neurons
now oligodendrocytes or arise from an
original cells from neural stem cells
about media station during mouse
embryonic development in around in
frankly 12.5 if more stem cells
originate embryonic collagen said
precursor cells or pcs that throughout
england genesis remain proliferative and
only at pony potato stages start
differentiating and then producing the
mining there is a suspect of these old
precursor cells that remain in the adult
central nervous system and they
constitute around 5% of themselves in
the federal nervous system and they're
in the almost quiet and state meaning
they are dividing very slowly however
upon specific stimuli they can be
activated start proliferating again and
then differentiate and produce smiling
and the one example of this for instance
is in multiples closest multiple
sclerosis
there is a pending attack against the
myelin leaping to the Emily nation and
this leads to a slower transmission of
electrical impulses in the central
nervous system and there leads to the
methodical symptoms that the patient
usually have in in the first stages of
the disease the patients have the
symptoms but then have a
recovery and the part of this recovery
is due to the fact that these alongside
precursor cells can migrate to the type
of lesions and then differentiate and
produce smiling doing them real
animation however when the disease
becomes in a progressive state and some
of these precursors can be still in in
the lesions but they fail to
differentiate and this is one of the
main questions that we are asking now
lab is how the epigenetic state of these
always a precursor cells and correlates
with their capacity to differentiate and
to myelinate now as I told you that that
is in Rio that all sites are generated
first specified in Briana Clah and then
studies from several groups have shown
that there is distinct ways of audience
that prefers a specification with the
first waves occurring both in the spinal
cord in the forebrain as in brows
demonically 12.5 then second way back in
chronic them with by 15.5 and then a
third final wave at postnatal stages and
this diversity of origin of the mossad
precursors then good suggestion that
they would regenerate different kinds of
oligodendrocytes and possibly with
different functions and however study
done by bill Richardson's group clearly
show that when you eliminate using the
exterior docking gene one of specific
wives some of these specific sufferers
and precursor cells as depicted here and
you can you have the other waves can
rescue the phenotype and can then
contribute to knowledge generation of
oligodendrocytes and the mice have
normal behavior such I think that these
different waves can be redundant and
then meaning that perhaps on the other
side and also be redundant however it
will go back in history and
into the 1920s when all the google sites
were described by PAP Delfi were tagged
and also later on by a builder Penfield
and they described using chemicals and
silver impregnation techniques four
kinds of oligodendrocytes
distinct morphologies already by that
time suggesting that all websites could
could have different could be
heterogeneous so in order to address
this as a logic as you have seen from
omits presentation singles RNA
sequencing is a very powerful technique
in order to examine whether indeed there
is a virginity in India you know site
lineage and and first in industry that
my group was also collaborating but it
was mainly driven by Stanley nationals
lab and me and Aaron Evans lab here and
here at our unit at Carnegie Institute
and in which I meet and also animal
shadow in the near zero vector lab were
the first authors and basically we think
of RNA sequencing was done in two
specific regions of the brain at the
somatosensory cortex and also Depot
campus using the technique that then I'm
it said in an unbiased way in order to
try to a
3005 cells were sequence and then
applying back spin as Amit described
nine classes of cells out within these
three thousand and five cells were
identified among which different kinds
of neurons astrocytes
oligodendrocytes and so far so this is
where our group stepped in because doing
a second double of analysis in a back
spin and we could we could detect that
there were six distinct populations of
all the good danger sites and here you
can see different genes that is here
every bar
correspond to a single cell and he'll
concede the different genes that are
expressed in the different six
populations that we have identified what
was also interesting in this analysis
was that here in blue you have cells
that come from the cortex and in yellow
cells that comes from Depot campus and
what we could see was at some
populations like this population illegal
3 was mainly present in the cortex but
not in people campus suggesting that was
cause for some regions ethnicity and
then this prompt is then to extend this
study and investigate the original
circuit virginity and and in the ten
different regions of the central nervous
system both in the dorsal to ventral
axis and also anterior-posterior axis
analyzing a total of five thousand and
seventy two cells of the oligodendrocyte
lineage again by single-cell RNA
sequencing and then adieu questioning
and up by clustering analysis this
discard was again peer headed in by
swell mozzarella mark she postdoc in my
lab and also i'm it in instance lab and
then in this delta find back spin and
then we go to correlation and gene
expression analysis what we identified
was twelve distinct oligodendrocyte cell
space with two precursor sites you know
muley formed oligodendrocyte stacks to
mine forming oligodendrocyte tag and
then six distinct mature states what was
also interesting was that we identified
and an additional cell state which we
call blmc
which express pd j r alpha which is one
of the canonical markers for all the
gunners and precursor cells but however
did not belong to deliver cycling each
and i'll talk a little bit more in
detail later on so and this is another
way to visualize the data this is a
disney plot where n
basically the it's a way to reduce the
multidimensionality of the data and
every single cell here is represented as
a single dot and if cells that are
similar to each other will be close to
the other news network
and what you can find what we could find
is that the two pdgfr populations were
clearly separated from the remaining
populations this vln see that that will
not belong to the one side lineage but
also the audience that precursor cells
cells and then we have a continuum of
cells of the exact lineage starting with
precursor cells newly formed
oligodendrocytes while informing and
then at the end we would have been fixed
mature all these inter-site populations
as going to go into detail in some of
these populations for instance even into
this blmc I have told you before this
sub population expressed PDGF are also a
Markov ago said precursor however did
not express sox10 which is a marker of
the illegal recycling age and and
express other markers for such as call 1
a 2 and others that were lower related
with the parasite lineage this also
presented some specific market that I'm
not in the parasite lineage like loan as
you can see here in this single molecule
fish which was performed by by Simone a
could not be in San Linda shallots
potentially National Lab and another
population that we were very interested
in was in this
committed precursors and also the
meaning from the legal danger sites and
which were expressed genes like the
transcription factor tcf7l2 and also an
ITP r2 and these cells were distinct
from all your site precursor cells as we
could not detect as little anymore
it'sso chemistry and in the
Dhruva noxian as they were not
overlapping with PDGF alpha and so they
were distinct however when we did
lineage tracing using the villager of
the gfp or village of the cree gfp and
we could see that they would excel that
were double labeled labeling for gfp and
IPPR - indicating that these cells were
definitely progeny of all such precursor
cells and in the post natal in the
indeed cortex and then in the in the
vine as positive the 21 we saw around
20% of the cells of the alongside cells
being ITP are two positives this
percentage was higher at Augmented a7
where myelination is really starting but
what was also very interesting that we
could detect at the at the adult mice
also in processing the corpus callosum
around 10% of the sixth and positive
cells being positive from IPPR to
indicating that these newly formed
oligodendrocytes are also present in the
adult brain and then suggesting that
they might have a function there so in
order to investigate that what we did
was that we started a collaboration with
Bill which turns lab in the UCL in UK
and the deal that had previously and
described and the complex field running
paradigm in which and mice are put in a
wheel and but some of the steps are
removed and because in other the mice
have to learn how to how to run in this
complex wheel and this process takes
entirety they can reach again the normal
speed on this complex field and so what
builds lab has shown in his in his study
was that my differentiation of
alienation from adult o pcs was
important for
this process of learning in this complex
will method paradigm and then in this
collaboration with will build up what we
examine what in English might after
three days under the complex motor
learning paradigm what was how delighted
we are to positive population is newly
formed oligodendrocytes and committed
precursors reacted and what we could see
was an increase in fifty percent of this
population in indicating that in this
complex motor learning paradigm this
population is indeed increase and
suggesting that it might have been a
function the India's paradigm so and if
we come back to our data one of the
advantages of having them and ten
different regions in the singles RNA
sequencing analysis is that we could
then be convolute the data and seeing
how the different cells that we have
identified were present in different
regions and one thing that we have
detected was for instance that some
regions like the striatum and the
substance in every BCI we could detect
very low numbers or even nod men of all
the mossad precursor cells which we
still don't know if it's and it really
reflects and the absence of these cells
in this regions or if it is more like a
question of a technical question of the
method at this point another depression
issue that we we could detect what that
was a common path the common path of
initial differentiation was present
throughout all the ten regions that we
have identified and but we also saw that
the mature cells were present in some
regions that we call them mature regions
were absent in other regions like
amygdala and hippocampus that are then
more imagery in this juvenile stage and
then we had some other regions that were
likely autonomous corpus callosum
straighten and Zone in certain that were
and regions where we could detect both
cells in both early stages and late
stages
so what we call an internet intermediate
stage of the original site lineage in
the juvenile brain and another way that
we can analyze the data isn't seeing the
different population that we have
identified however they are enriched in
the different regions that we have
examined and what we could see for
instance was that some of the material
population seemed to be particularly
enriched in some of the regions that we
have identified and suggesting that that
also that so that this thing materialism
site types are then present in enriching
specific regions and we could also in
our in this dataset we also really need
not only these are single-cell RNA
sequencing in the juvenile juvenile mice
but we also did in the adult cortex and
corpus callosum and with this we could
also compare do a temporal apart from
the special operation that I should
should be before and also a temple
compression of comparison of these and
of the different populations and what we
could see for instance what that
audience that precursor cells
undetermined that here so in the
juvenile my are the cells are labeled
here in red while in the adult mice are
labeled in blue and we could see that
was not made much of a difference
between the the translational profiles
of the juvenile and adult or pcs in
between this into these different stages
except at the cell cycle level where we
could see that for instance of our cells
in then in the juvenile mice has a
higher number of cell cycle genes being
expressed in comparison with those OB
seized from the adult mice which then
correlates with
affecting the literature for instance
from the bill which since lab that
indicates that the cell cycle time of
juvenile focuses in juvenile life
it's faster than in the jobs that are in
the other place and another thing that
we could also detect was the the death
present no matter the material size of
oligodendrocytes and from the state's
appeared in the journal might but then
appear to disappear in the process in
the cortex in India both in the adult
cortex but some other cell types were
appeared mainly in the adult mice so
Jackie then that perhaps some of these
material types might be achieved already
at the juvenile stage but might be in
some places transient while other of the
material states can only be achieved in
the material in the adult brain so and
of course having this diversity of six
different types of mature or little
enterocytes
one question that is that would be quite
interesting to follow them is here do
they not have different functions and we
have started assessing this by doing
gene ontology analysis of of this
dataset and one thing that we could see
well is that in these metal populations
they all expressed genes involved in
myelination however a subset of them
percent among five alone six that are
present more in the adult corpus
callosum and and cortex they present
genes again reaching genes involved in
sinuses and one example of this is the
Metro traffic ultimatum researcher grm 3
we then then did an analysis of other
ultimate receptors and other channels
expressed in our dataset and what we
could see is that the different
populations express this receptor
although it expresses
many of them expressed it in a scattered
wipe and so so applying thing of an RNA
sequencing as Amit explaining the first
part of this webinar allows allowed us
then to dissect the heterogeneity of the
original site lineage in the central
nervous system open the juvenile might
and also in in the adult life and then
from this dataset it's the conclusion
that we took is that firstly we appeal
to the CNS is the first population that
we found find in the initial steps of
differentiation mainly the orbital
precursor cell the committed precursor
then the newly formed oligodendrocytes
well into and then the myelin forming
one and two but then we we appear to see
a region specificity when it comes to
the material organ aside populations and
with some some cell some of these cell
states being expressed being present in
in some regions more than in others the
other aspect is also that some of these
populations in b2b be present more in
the adult versus in the juvenile brain
indicating also a temporal aspect in the
distribution of these immature rolling
on your side populations so with this we
we would like to acknowledge the people
that have contributed to the work in
this that we have presented I mean in my
lab and also the lineage lab where
Arabic is and also several other labs
with internal changes event specifically
in our unit that have contributed to the
studies namely the young masters lab and
em first
- and an exam also to be alerted that we
have collaborated for the complex will
motor learning paradigm and also the
funding agency and
and also stand left center and other
lamps and that happened at this study
and so with this I would like to give
the word to mm and then me and M it will
be after that with this presentation
will be here to answer any questions
that you might have and okay thanks
Emmett and Gonzalo I would not I would
now like to tell you about some of the
products and resources that we have
adapt cam that can help you with your
RNA and oligodendrocyte research many of
you will be aware of our range of
products we have several antibodies to
oligodendrocyte markers our key
antibodies against markers for mature
oligodendrocytes oligodendrocyte
specific protein antibody rated five
star and referenced in ten papers myelin
basic protein antibody rated five star
in reference in seventeen papers myelin
oligodendrocyte glycoprotein antibody
rated five star and reference in three
papers Olek to antibody also rated five
star and socks an antibody referenced in
three papers we test all according to
Simon antibodies in to make sure that
they work in IFC and ICC as well as
other applications you can find out how
other researchers have used these
antibodies by looking at the user
reviews and the publication's listed on
each of the product datasheets
on our website I'd like to draw your
attention to the aaalac two and sixteen
antibodies for a moment which are
labeled rap mob
these are rabbit monoclonal antibodies
and are ideal for staining mouse or rat
tissues versus mouse monoclonal
antibodies
as featured in the science paper from
today's speakers different types of
mature oligodendrocytes are enriched for
particular markers for example we have
seen how metal worktop metabotropic
glutamate receptor 3 gr n3 labels mole 6
oligodendrocytes in the paper the
authors confirmed this by IHC using our
anti metabotropic glutamate receptor 3
antibody a B one four zero seven four
one in addition to markers for mature
oligodendrocytes we also cover markers
for oligodendrocyte precursor cells here
are two examples PDGF receptor alpha
antibody rated five star and ng - 1 D
body rated four and a half stars and
referenced in six papers these two are
tested to ensure they work in Nice
united c and icc in addition we have
many resources around neuron and marcus
and i you see on our website these
include for example a guide to neuronal
markers a specific one on shown cell
markers and their functions egg layer
and demyelinating pasta and an IFC
application guide we also have many
resources around RNA and epigenetics on
our website which you can find all in
one place on the epigenetics portal at
app calm calm slash epigenetics here you
can find useful information on
applications such as RNA
immunoprecipitation micro RNA profiling
and chip-sequencing
thank you for listening and I will now
hand you to my colleague Jessica to
start the Q&A session
okay so we have a question from our
audience on the RNA six technology so
this is probably for Amit the question
is are there available methods for
single-cell RNA sake analysis that would
include poly a - RNAs
so by large I think the answer is is no
so majority of the particles that are
available today and people use a using a
quality primer for the western kitchen
but I think there are people that I know
walking on it I don't know if it's
publisher or not micro in a in finger
cell I think even a fluid I maybe have a
kid so my colony and some people that do
RNA from nuclear RNA and then they need
to use some kind of random partners to
to start their work encryption again the
problem is how to avoid the ribosomal
RNA and when you do it in single cell
and you cannot make any depletion okay
we have a second question from the
audience and and this is on backspin so
this probably forum it again and the
question is in backspin when should the
splitting of the clusters stop
yeah okay so yeah of course which is the
million-dollar question of the film what
is the so felt whether there is a
general walking stopping condition and
how many clusters one would expect and I
don't think again that there is a very
clear answer to this question it doesn't
matter which casting method you use
there's always you need to tune the
parameter
and basically run the methods with
different parameters and see where
things make sense particularly for
Bechstein basically the main parameter
is how many splits to do and again this
is very different depending on the cells
you analyze and what we do is a
practical guide what I can say that what
you can do you can always try to do
larger number of splits and either the
sometimes the algorithm identify can
identify that there is no need to split
more and this is the good case and in
other cases it will still split but then
you need to evaluate the clustering
results and inspect them manually and
this is basically what we use usually do
as a standard practice
we're on the back spin and again
depending on the data you need to have a
little bit a feeling of harmony and
splits you you should ask and then you
should anyway evaluate the result of the
clustering by looking whether two
clusters are really different and have
any n kind of different and what we
usually do in case that there is no
difference we can merge the cuttin so
the ruling based kind of unsupervised
analysis is that we don't create a
clusters based on markers we don't
create the clusters in any arbitrary way
based on previous knowledge we let the
algorithm do it the only thing we can do
it to merge clusters after they already
okayed yes okay thank summit we have a
third question from the flow and this I
see might be for Gonzalo it's on
oligodendrocytes populations so what do
you think are the functions of the
different oligodendrocyte populations
you have identified
okay so this is something like I could
do it in the presentation that we've
been starting to address first
bye-zee-bye gene ontology what what they
could put two different populations what
genes they are enriched in that whether
they can give us like a groove on which
function that they might is exert and
but what one thing that we are actively
doing now in the lab is correlating some
of these markers that we have identified
and the disorder causing different
social profiles between
immunohistochemistry so we can be able
to see within the brain and the spinal
cord where the cells are their
morphology and then from that point on
and try to investigate what kind what
kind of neurons they must be interacting
and what kind of function they might be
having so one thing that I mentioned
also was in the during the webinar was
at some of the populations like mo 5 and
6 were engaged in genes associated with
them inverted in associated synaptic
communication and so forth and there was
a last year in August the attacker from
Peter Styles lab in Canada where they
developed the concept of axial Melnik my
Linux eye labs and I think that perhaps
some of the functions of these different
populations might be related with this
action myelin communication yes so the
video that's what my answer yes we have
an additional question from the floor
this might be for you Gonzalo again it's
on multiple sclerosis so you mentioned
multiple sclerosis in the beginning of
the talk are de-identified
oligodendrocyte populations present and
affected in ms lesions okay so this is
so our our study that we have done so
far as I saw in the webinar were my men
in the juvenile and adult healthy mice
and what we are now really focusing in
our
again investigating by single RNA
sequencing dueling site lineage in the
context of disease so this is something
that we are very much interested and and
everything that this kind of technique
can give us very useful insights because
for instance all of the population that
we identified this IPPR to positive
population we think we're going to
screening the literature it has been
previously shown that lesions of MS
patients have an OPC that a proportion
of audience of precursors that very
paradoxically are ki-67 negatives so
they are not proliferating and and they
have other market like MKX 2.2 and when
going back to our data set these are
very similar to for this committed
precursors on militant oligodendrocyte
population that we have identified that
iri TPR to positive and so we think
actually that those operations in
english' might be these new populations
that we have identified and so this is
why we think it's quite interesting to
to examine this in the now in the
context of disease okay thanks there's
another question from the floor and the
question is what are the criteria to
design or prepare um i who wants to take
this yeah we'll take it Amit so
basically you are my is a general name
for a set of formal nucleotides in it
really depends where there is the oh my
but basically we have it on the
templates which are ago so it depends if
your temperature zero is made out of DNA
or RNA or some special nucleotides in
our case it's it's in having any article
so there is no special criteria except
the the size of the number of
nucleotides inside this set of
fundamental time
and of course the longer the um I
you can encode larger number of molecule
like about more more more and more
molecules because it's just a number of
combinations that you can get from a set
of uh nucleotides in our case it's it's
six so it's up to almost four thousand
combinations that are possible and for
this application is it's more than
enough people use um I also in a three
point protocol so the protocol is I
describe is five point protocol people
are now using a lot of Sipan protocol
where they use the UM I on the strip and
side on the quality and then they need
longer your mind and they use your mind
which is up to ten but again the UN
myself has nothing special it's just on
the nucleotides that you buy from
one of the standard companies without
any anything special that one okay so
the next question is on single cell
isolation is it possible to explain how
the single cells are isolated yes
so again in this study what I described
is is is basically the use of of the
freedom platform the freedom platform
again it's a it's a micro fluidics
that's all that basically and the sense
are flowing in a channel and this
channel has I will try to highlight that
most people see this capture site and
basically these necessar flowing through
a channel and the channel has a capture
site which is just some geometrical
shape that cells tend to attract them
and once they get they are stuck in this
capture site again it's designed in a
way that more cells are less likely to
get
stacked on the same capture site so
basically the cells are not isolated one
by one what you do you load into this
predict the basically a cell suspension
which is basically after you dissociate
the tissue you have a cell suspension
with the concentration of a few hundred
cells per microliter and this is you
load about five to ten microliters into
the chip and the Machine basically
pushed those cells into the microphone X
channel until you and this process takes
about thirty minutes and then you go and
image this chip and you see how many if
the cells got capture of a billion got
capture or how many got captured we are
I could have perhaps that I mean before
this isolation stepped there is also the
extraction step and this is like one of
the key things in them singles RNA
sequencing because it will affect what
cell we would have represented when you
are doing the analysis so it's actually
a step that involved this paper that we
have presented and took a lot of
optimization in order to get the cells
in the right State in order to be able
to do was single some RNA sequencing I
mean we are working with a brain and
spinal cord which have a lot of myelin
and it's particularly difficult so
depending on your tissue of interest it
might be easier or not to do this
extraction step so there is indeed one
more question from the floor and it is
what is other information that can be
derived from RNA sequencing other than
gene expression
so basically I mean the measurement is
gene expression that were but of course
the gene expression is again contain a
lot of information again in this kind of
platform and again this is just one
example of platform for signal 781 can
also image the sense with standard
epifluorescence microscope so you can
get basically the byte field that tells
you the shape and the size and any other
fluorescence channel but other than this
today there are other protocols not the
protocol that I described that can do
basically DNA sequencing in RNA from the
scenes in and DNA and methylation I am
exhalation and other combinations of
particles that can basically take
measurements on a single cell and get
more than just the ion yes I would just
add up to of course when you get these
gene expression profiles in the single
cell level you can have then try to to
deduce what kind of transcription
networks are operating in individual
cells and what kind of transcription
factors are driving but if you solve
analysis that that would be predictive
and then you would need to go to
techniques like and it has referred to
in order to confirm that those chromatin
types that allow the gene expression and
having these acceleration dog head of
cells and so like I mean after DNA
methylation sequencing anything also has
been development but also like ataxic
then a single cell has also been
published recently so I think it's it's
a time you can see the gene expression
uh no this is a static central point for
other investigations and like in our
case in our lab we are in significant
ethics and
this is a really good tool to have